MARK MIRCHANDANI: Not sure where
to look for your Google Cloud
Platform payment details?
In this video,
we'll cover what you
need to know about payment
methods, your GCP invoice,
and where to go to answer
detailed cost questions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When you use a GCP
resource, you'll
need a method to pay for it.
And there's two
ways to do this--
online or invoiced.
Online, also sometimes
referred to as self-service,
is where payments are made
online with a credit or debit
card.
This is the default option
when setting up a billing
account using Google
Cloud Platform.
Invoiced is where a
request for payment
is made through an invoice.
And payment is made through
a check or a wire transfer.
This method is sometimes
referred to as offline billing.
Some customers are eligible
to change their billing method
to a monthly invoice
billing structure.
Eligibility depends on a
variety of factors, including
how long your account
has been active,
the typical amount of
your monthly spend,
and your country.
An invoice billing account
is much more common
for larger organizations.
If you have a dedicated
finance or accounting team
or if you anticipate
a large GCP spend,
you'll want to work with your
GCP sales team or billing
support to set up an
invoice billing account.
The key thing to remember
is that all customers
receive a monthly PDF
summarizing their costs
from the previous month.
Customers who are using
the online payment method
receive a monthly statement.
Customers who have switched
to invoice billing account
receive a PDF invoice, which
is the request for payment.
An invoice for a
particular month
should be available
by the fifth business
day of the following month.
For example, your
September invoice
will be ready no
later than October 5.
Invoices aren't generated on
weekends or bank holidays.
So you should expect
invoices to be
delayed during those periods.
If you want to receive
invoices by email,
or you want to change
who receives invoices,
refer to the payments contacts
and notification settings
managing your payments profile.
Now, before we take a closer
look at the sample invoice,
the first thing you
need to know is this--
an invoice essentially
tells you what you owe.
That's about it.
If you want to get a full
picture of your GCP costs
and answer detailed
cost questions,
you should refer to the billing
reports in the GCP console.
So when in doubt, remember--
your invoice tells you
what you owe.
Billing reports tell you why
and where your cost came from.
Now, let's take a
look at the details
included in a typical invoice.
Here's a sample invoice.
On the first page,
you can expect
to find some key
pieces of information.
First off, you can see who
the invoice is addressed to.
This information would have
been provided to Google
at the time invoice
billing account was set up.
To edit or update
this information,
refer to the payments
profile settings.
Next, you'll find details, such
as the invoice date, payment
terms, which is usually
full payment within 30 days,
and the account ID.
The account ID might
be helpful in cases
where you're inquiring
about specific charges
on your invoice.
If you're not able to
resolve your questions
with the help of your
billing account admin,
you can request that they submit
a ticket to the Google Cloud
support team.
Only your billing account
admins can create a ticket
with billing support.
On the right, you'll
also see the total amount
owed in a single
currency and a line item
showing the taxes applied.
All discounts
previously negotiated
as part of your
Google Cloud agreement
would have already been
applied to the total.
And at the bottom
of the first page,
you'll find instructions
for paying your invoice
either by wire
transfer or by check.
In subsequent pages,
you'll see a summary table
with details based on
your GCP consumption.
The first column is the product.
It's fairly self-explanatory.
It refers to the GCP service
that reported the billing data.
Resource type is a
brief description
of the specific resource
that was used by the service.
For example, a resource type
of line item for Compute Engine
is the charge for static IPs.
Next, is the interval, which
lists the start and end
dates of resource usage
for that billing cycle.
Usage lists the quantity
of the service used.
You might notice the
unit of consumption
will differ depending
on the resource type.
For example, a VPN tunnel
under Compute Engine
will be listed in hours.
And finally, for
each row, you'll
see the calculated
cost under amount.
Note that the calculated cost
includes your discounted rate.
If you want to see a
more detailed breakout
of your costs, refer
to the billing reports
in the GCP console.
Let's look at an example
of how resource types
for a specific
product are priced,
such as for Compute Engine.
Charges are based on compute
instances, storage, and network
use.
Virtual machines are
charged on per second basis
with a one minute minimum usage.
Storage is calculated based on
the amount of data you store.
Network cost is calculated
based on the amount of data
transferred between virtual
machine instances that
communicate with each other
and with the internet.
To learn more about how various
resource types are priced,
refer to
cloud.google.com/pricing.
If you need to view previous
invoices or invoices past due,
you can access them
in the console.
Using the left-hand
navigation, click
Billing to choose
a billing account,
and then select Invoices.
From this page, you can filter
by all invoices and memos
or just by open ones.
It's also easy to
create custom filters
and search so that you can find
the information that you're
looking for.
Clicking on an item lets
you see the full detail,
such as the invoice number,
amount, and payment due date.
In addition, you can
download a PDF version
if you want to share the
invoice between teams
or even download a CSV version,
which makes it easier to parse.
Remember, the invoice
is intentionally
designed to show you a
summary of what you owe.
Depending on your
specific need, you
might have additional questions.
Here's a few tips for where
you can get more information.
Get to know your organization's
GCP billing account admins.
There may be more than one
admin in your organization.
And working together to plan,
track, and pay for your GCP
costs will prove
helpful in the long run.
If you're looking for detailed
views of your GCP costs,
refer to the billing
reports in the GCP console.
If you want to review the price
list for different resource
types, check out the Google
Cloud pricing website
or access the
information via the API.
For more information about your
invoice or to resolve common
billing issues, check out
cloud.google.com/billing/docs.
That's it for payment
methods and invoices.
Check out the links to
learn more information.